>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Music ]
>> David Rubenstein: Hello.
My name is David Rubenstein and
I have the honor and privilege
of serving this year
as the cochairman
of the 16th National Book
Festival, brought to you
by the Library of Congress.
National Book Festival was begun
in 2001 and it was designed
to bring people from all over the
country together in Washington DC,
authors, people who care
about books, people who care
about literacy, as a way
of promoting literacy
and promoting books, and
it's worked quite well.
I, as a young boy,
began to read books
when I first got my library
card at the age of 6.
And from that time on, I've
spent an enormous amount
of time reading books, learning
from books and helping to get others
to get access to books because
in my view, if you read books,
you have a chance of
enjoying life much more,
but you also have a chance of
being a better human being.
What we now have this
year, on September 24th
at the Walter E. Washington
Convention Center, is a gathering
of - probably be about 100,000
people and more than 100 authors.
And for those who have the
chance to come to this occasion,
I would highly recommend it
because you'll have a chance
to meet the most famous
authors in the country and from
around the world, have a chance to
hear them read from their books,
have a chance to listen to them talk
about their books, and have a chance
to get their books autographed.
But in addition, it's a chance
for adults and children,
it's not for just children, it's not
just for adults, it's for everybody,
and it doesn't cost anything.
It is free, so I encourage
people to take advantage
of this free opportunity to come to
Washington on September the 24th,
meet authors that you've read about
before, that you've wanted to meet
and having a chance to really
appreciate the importance of books.
This will be an occasion
that you will not forget.
So thanks very much for
listening to this and I hope
to see you on September the 24th.
Thank you.
>> Cokie Roberts: This festival is
a remarkable celebration of books
and reading and so having
families come to this festival
and understand the importance of
those books for children is one
of the key elements of making this
a success, not only for the authors,
which it is, but also for the
country and that's appropriate
for our country's library to do.
[ Music ]
>> David McCullough: To me, it's one
of the greatest events
of each American year.
>> Jeffery Deaver: National
Book Festival is a phenomenon.
[ Music ]
>> Guy Lamolinara: Our 16th annual
celebration of books and reading,
the Library of Congress
National Book Festival promises
to be the best we've ever had.
>> Marie Arana: One of the really
wonderful things that we're adding
to the festival this year,
we've never had it
before, is a main stage.
>> Guy Lamolinara: And this will be
a stage for our super star authors
that will seat 2500 people.
>> Marie Arana: We have Stephen
King, Karim Abdul-Jabbar,
Salman Rushdie, Shonda Rhimes,
Raina Telgemeier, Bob Woodward.
>> Guy Lamolinara: I think we
have the best lineup of authors
in the history of the festival.
[ Music ]
>> For me, I think it's
just a nexus of technology
but also the love of reading.
>> It's just overwhelming.
>> The Book Festival is always
a highlight of the year.
>> Every year my wife and
I mark it on our calendar.
>> I think it's special
because other kids, like me,
who are interested in books get
to learn more information
and more things.
>> It's huge, you know, because
everybody comes here for books.
It's what the whole thing's about.
>> It's kind of like a gathering
point of literary Washington.
>> I went the first year
in 2008 and after that,
I just come every single year
because I have so much fun.
[ Music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.